hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar latest technologies in antibody
and protein labeling i am sydney mcneil
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
douglas anderson scientist 3
chemistry r d thermo fisher scientific
doug you may now begin your presentation
all right thanks for that great
introduction we'll go ahead and get
started
my name is douglas anderson i'm a
research uh research and development
scientist here at thermo fisher
scientific and i'm going to be going
over some latest technologies and
antibody and protein labeling
before we get started i wanted to
overview what we're going to cover in
today's webinar we're going to start
with some basics just to make sure
everybody's on the same page some
general information about conjugation
basics um how the workflows come out um
types of applications you might be using
conjugation for um and then moving on to
some more nitty gritty with one of the
questions i get all the time as a
conjugation chemist which is you know
how do you select conjugation approach
and how do you pick a floor for what is
the right conjugation for you
whether you're going to create your own
conjugate in the lab using a kit or
freehand or if you're going to purchase
a conjugate for your experiment
and then lastly i'm going to be covering
some of the state-of-the-art
improvements um in conjugation chemistry
um both some products here at thermo
fisher scientific some workflow
improvements um and some products for
purchase that have really pushed the
boundaries of the the conjugation
chemistry in general and push the push
the rounds of what you can do at the
bench and what you can do in your
experiments to really get you premier
reagents for to give you the best
success in your next round of
experiments
so diving right into it uh what is
conjugation so
conjugation is the technical term we
like to use that really just refers to
any kind of biomolecule labeling so
conjugation is a you know series of
chemistry uh techniques that in general
we use it to refer to any kind of
labeling of a biomolecule um this is
most often an antibody or protein of
interest but it can be really any kind
of biomolecules so nucleic acids any
kind of biopolymers glycan dextrans
really anything in life sciences that
you want to attach some kind of label um
to this biomolecule and this label can
be really almost anything that suits
your application it's most often a
fluorescent label or perhaps a
colometric label they can also be small
molecules uh haptins biotin other
proteins or crosslinkers really the
sky's the limit as far as what you want
but everything in in and that we call
conjugation shares
in common some kind of a labeling of a
biomolecule
that you're going to be using in some
kind of downstream application for an
experiment
um on the right here we have an example
of what a actual conjugate
looks like so this for me i'm very
visual and i really enjoy thinking about
what an actual bioconjugate would look
like so this here in this example of a
crystal structure model of an antibody
that's been labeled with alexa 4 647 to
give you an idea of what this looks like
here the green residues are highlighting
lysines which are the particular target
for this for this little report
so moving on to
what we know what a conjugate is how do
you make them um one of the reasons i
like to start here is you know if you're
unfamiliar with with bio conjugates uh
you know people often have an idea that
they're quite challenging and in reality
they're actually
for the most part fairly easy to make
but generally producing a conjugate
whether you're making one from scratch
or buying a kit it is pretty
straightforward most
most conjugates are made in about three
or four steps uh you have a general
prepping some reagents for use in the in
the reaction that you'll be performing
um most of these reactions are simple
one-step reactions that take place
between one to three hours at room
temperature so nothing too fancy
followed up by generally a single step
purification to remove any excess
labeling reagent and then finally a
quantification
of that biomolecule that you've created
before it's ready for use so in general
depending on the label and the workflows
that we'll be talking about today
most conventional conjugates you'll find
on the market can be made within a few
hours
and depending on the workflows it can
sometimes take a little longer if you're
making a more complicated workflow or
more complicated reagent but most of the
conjugates you'll see
on the market and reagents for are
relatively straightforward to make
yourself if you're
wanting to make one yourself for your
next experiment
so before i move on i'm going to be
talking about a couple general
conjugation chemistries here to
highlight the types of chemistries and
the approaches that you can take when
making a bioconjugate but i do want to
point out that this is this webinar is
not intended to be a super detailed uh
um overview of everything that's out
there uh there's quite a lot of great
resources out there if you'd like to
really dig into the nitty-gritty of all
the various chemistries that are out
there and the different types of
approach
so i'd like to point out the molecular
probes handbook it's actually made
thermo fisher scientific for free you
can get one of these copies online and
this goes into all the all the various
details of all the different types of
chemistries all the products that are
out there how to go through a conjugate
all the the
interesting details between the
different reactive groups available
there's also a textbook an excellent
textbook bioconjugate techniques by greg
carmenson that is literally the book on
bioconjugation that has all the detail
one could ever want as far as how to
attach a label on a biomolecule
lastly there's also another webinar from
a colleague of mine that was made in
2016 that's available for free on
youtube
that where she describes in in full
detail all the various conjugation
chemistries um in all their glory uh but
for here i'm going to to stick to kind
of the the four
most popular conjugation techniques and
just really cover the general
conjugation chemistries that you might
see
in a conjugate or they might use in the
lab
so in general there's four classes of
conjugation chemistries and it's
easiest to think about how these
conjugation chemistries what are they
targeting what are they reacting with on
the biomolecule this will really help
determine uh what type of approach you
might want to use or what type of
country you might want to purchase if
you're going to be buying them they have
different pros and cons which we'll
actually go to in a few slides here but
i do want to highlight these four
general categories
of the types of chemistries that they're
doing and these can be generally broken
down into four categories so you have
your amine targeted so these are
reactive compounds that are targeting
the lysines and proteins or any free
amino groups if you're looking at a
dextran or a glycan
you have sulfhydryl targeted reactive
groups so these are going to target the
cysteines and proteins um
less then you have some cross-linking
reactions that are generally used to
cross-link proteins to make
protein-protein conjugates
so these are
designed to have controlled
cross-linkings to give you well-defined
conjugates between large proteins such
as
apc rpe gsp or
enzymes of interest to produce you know
protein protein conjugates and often
these are antibody conjugates to either
an enzyme or a large protein floor for
lastly you have one of the newer
categories which is click chemistry
and
this is probably one of the newest ones
that we have on the market and i've
actually got a couple slides dedicated
to some of the recent advancements in
click chemistry
so i'll step through these four
categories in in brief um and highlight
kind of what are the reactions that
we're looking like what are the reactive
groups
before we move on to the pros and cons
so the first group the amine target is
this is by far the most uh common and
popular
strategy for labeling a bioconjugate so
these uh
these reactive groups um
target as i mentioned the lysines of
proteins and these are usually simple
one-step reactions
and most common of which is what's
called an nhster so these uh
labels usually fluorophores will have
this simple
nhs group that will target
the
lysines on a given given protein of
interest um and you have a simple one
step reaction at mild alkaline
conditions and after about an hour at
these conditions you'll be left with a
stable covalent amide bond between your
label of interest and your protein and
then you'll have the leading group the
nhs group to be purified off in the
downstream purification
these are by far the most common
conjugates produced they're very stable
they're easy to produce
the reaction is very well
well characterized
and they're they're easy to do as an end
user if you just want a straightforward
conjugate
there are other reactive groups that you
might see on the market generally
speaking
they all more or less do the same thing
some of which are a little less
susceptible to water hydrolysis but in
general
all the mean targeted
chemistries like nhs ester sdp ester
tsps that you'll see on the market
all more or less target that it means in
the same way and have similar reaction
conditions
second most popular conjugation
chemistry group would be sulfhydryl
targeted so as i mentioned these are
reactive groups that are targeting the
cysteines on proteins so
these reagents here react with the
reduced sulfhydryl groups of cysteines
and proteins
these similar to the amine targeted
these are usually a simple malayamide
reactive group um so seen here uh very
similar to the nhs group which is that
extra double bond um these react with
reduced sulfur hydrol's at a neutral ph
in about an hour
sometimes a little bit more hour hour
and a half two hours
to produce a stable thio ether bond
so these uh sulfhydryl chemistry is also
very easy to to do at the bench uh quick
reaction times well characterized uh
these chemistry has been around for a
long time so also have a very nice easy
workflow of a single one-shot reaction
followed by purification
so another another good classic choice
to put a label on a biomolecule
the third group we hear uh is a little
more general i've called the protein
protein cross-linking group um so if you
have the need to put a protein onto
another protein so most often an
antibody conjugate with either a enzyme
of sort uh often it's another
fluorescent protein conjugate so in this
case what you're you're trying to
produce a controlled cross-linking event
between two large proteins um so there's
a number of regions out there that are
designed to produce these
well-controlled crosslinking i emphasize
well-controlled because if they're done
as the
stoichiometries are off or if they're
poorly controlled you can get a
too much cross-linking and you'll end up
with a just a large protein goop which
won't do anybody any good so you'll have
a this family is
more about the cross-linkers themselves
one of the most common cross-linkers
that you see is is actually a
combination of the first two chemistries
so one example here is a sulfur sncc
crosslinker and this is basically a um
an nhs ester with a short
linker itself
a linker of linkers really where you're
just linking a a mean targeting nhs
group with a sulfur hydraulic targeted
uh
malayamid and so you can basically pop
one side of the linker onto your first
protein under uh one of the conditions
for one of the reactor groups and then
you follow it up with your second
protein and you use the second reactive
groups reactive conditions and this
two-step method lets you have a
well-defined um cross-linking event
where you can control the amount of
cross-linking between the two to give
you a well-characterized protein
conjugate
and the last group i want to talk about
here is the click chemistry so this is a
newer group of reactions uh reactivities
for biocomplications and this is
actually a two-step process
that involves a reaction between a azide
modified biomolecule and then a
cyclooctine modified biomolecule
and the benefit of these using quick
chemistry between this azide and
cyclooctine is that this is a highly
efficient bio-orthogonal catalyst-free
reaction
and one of the major benefits to this
type of conjugation is it can actually
occur in vivo so you can use it to
create uh stable conjugates in test tube
of course but it there's a whole product
lines uh involving using click chemistry
in vivo as well
uh these reactions are again highly
efficient so they usually go to full
completion and sometimes purification is
not even required uh and in in this uh
reaction scheme here uh no catalyst is
needed either so it's very gentle on the
conjugate
and i'm gonna be providing a little more
detail in a few slides about our cyclic
technology which takes this chemistry to
the next level to really give ideal
conjugates
all right so now that we have a general
overview of you know what is
conjugations how do you perform
conjugations one of the major questions
i get as a as a conjugation biochemist
all the time is
how do i pick a conjugate what is the
right conjugate for me what's the right
conjugate for my application i always
when i'm answering these questions i
really ask you know uh
what is your application what is your as
an end user what do you need um in the
different chemistries and floor force
available will have different
suitabilities depending on your
application um so some of the most
common applications for a bioconjugate
often an antibody fluorescent conjugate
um i have four applications listed here
there are others of course and your
needs may vary but in general most
conjugates fall into either
immunocytochemistry or you're trying to
take a picture on a microscope flow
cytometry with primary fluorescent label
antibody conjugates antibody drug
conjugates for research use in
ultimately coming up with ivds or
perhaps an in vitro assay
so walking through these four
conjugation chemistries um what are they
best suited for so with the mean
labeling um as i mentioned when going
over the the general conjugation
chemistries this is a very tried and
true labeling method it's extremely
straightforward and also inexpensive
as this has been on the market for 30 40
years and is really the gold standard
when it comes to antibody conjugates
these conjugates while they're
they're straightforward and relatively
simple uh they more often than not are
able to meet the needs of kind of your
workhorse applications so that the
immunocytochemistry perhaps if you're
making a secondary conjugate or if you
want to go with a one-step primary
conjugate um even though the technology
for this is relatively uh has been
around the market for quite some time
these conjugates are often more than
bright enough for most applications and
are really the gold standard when it
comes to most labeling experiments
whether that's a simple icc stain a
float cytometry or an in vitro assay
one
sometimes can be a con of this method is
that because these reagents are
targeting the lysines on proteins
depending on the protein size there is
often uh dozens of these lysines so that
means when you're making a conjugate
these reagents are
um
randomly labeling the lysines on these
proteins so for a given antibody most
antibodies have around 50. so if you
have a conjugate that has you know three
or four
fluorescent labels for example those
could be anywhere on the antibody
and depending on your replication that
that often doesn't matter
but sometimes especially if you're
trying to make let's say an antibody
drug conjugate or you really want to
have that fluorescent the fluorophore
ratio well controlled this uh this
labeling technique might not be as
precise for that technique so again
these meeks make excellent workhorse
conjugates if you're doing kind of
traditional workflows that are well
established these are the conjugates for
you these are been been the gold
standard for uh for life sciences
research for
for decades now and they still have uh
lots of use in in today's experiments
so next up we have the malayamaid
sulfhydryl labeling um so this is kind
of an interesting chemistry for
applications so as i mentioned here
because these conjugates or these
reactive groups target the um
cysteines in proteins most proteins have
uh
significantly less histines than they
have lysines so what this means is that
even though the cystine labeling
with these
these
reagents
is still somewhat random in the sense of
what cysteines it hits because there's
significantly less cysteines you
generally have a good idea of where
these are going to go based off the
sequence of your protein so this is an
antibody the systems are are you know
well mapped out
so you more or less know where your
systems are going to be um so this makes
for a good application for um conditions
where you really want that control over
the labeling you want to know where your
where your floor force or your your
label of interest is going to be so it
gives you that labeling control and
because it's hitting a much smaller pool
of systems
you have improved repeatability just
simply because there's less options for
them to label so you're going to have
more of a a lot to lot um repeatability
between labeling so you're not going to
have nearly as much of that randomness
and these protocols are just as easy to
follow as a mean targeted reagent so you
have a nice workhorse
labeling that is easy to do with the
bench but also that gives you a little
bit more of a well-defined um a
well-defined conjugate
one of the big cons though of the sulfur
hydro-targeted reagent is that because
you're targeting these cysteines which
are usually significantly less than the
lysines most of these conjugates are
going to have significantly less
fluorophores per antibody or poor
protein so they often have a lot lower
signal to noise than a traditionally
labeled conjugate so you really want to
when you if you're looking at
implementing this into your workflows
you really want to consider is the
trade-off of signal the potential for
lower signal worth it for that extra
control
and this really becomes um really useful
in in vitro assays where if you're using
a protein where you can genetically
manipulate the sequence perhaps you can
add a cysteine at the end
at the
the n-terminus or the or the the end of
the protein if you can control the
location that's cysteine you have great
control over what exactly where you're
putting that floor for so it might not
interfere with your protein so if you
have an in vitro assay this where you
can have that level control this is a
great method for you um
and it's also great for if you're trying
to make a defined antibody drug
conjugate where repeatability is quite
important and maybe you're not putting a
fluorescent fluorophore you're putting
some kind of a you know a drug where you
only need one or two of those so this is
a great it's a great method if you if
you need that control and that
repeatability above all else
all right next up we have our click
labeling which i mentioned earlier uh so
click labeling um
has really come into its own as one of
the premier labeling technologies
and i'm actually going to spend a couple
slides dedicated solely to talking about
cyclic which is one of our premier
labeling technologies at thermo fisher
scientific
but click chemistry has really become
quite useful in making really well
exceptionally well-defined conjugates um
that are very well controlled and very
well repeatable um with also efficient
workflows uh so in
most uh click chemistry especially our
cyclic platform these workflows provide
very well controlled labeling
as the labeling is is con is specific to
a certain type a certain position on the
antibody
um and so this gives you exceptional
labeling control it gives you
exceptional repeatability and i'll go
into a little bit more detail about our
cyclic platform here in a few slides but
in general these click platforms that
are out there on the market give um
fantastic fluorophores or fantastic
conjugates uh with well-defined number
of fluorophores per per antibody or
protein the reactions themselves are
very efficient so it there's less to
clean up in your purification step and
sometimes to the point where you don't
even need to do a cleanup
however these these workflows can be a
little bit more expensive and they do
add a little bit of extra hands-off time
doing the performing the extra steps to
to generate the intermediates that are
needed
such as the azide activated antibody in
this figure here so where this really
becomes uh very helpful is if you have a
an application where you need a
exceptionally high performing antibody
where you need
you really need everything you want to
preserve the integrity of your antibody
you want to preserve the integrity of
your protein at all costs and this is a
great method for that because it keeps
your your labels away from the binding
sites or perhaps the biological activity
of another protein
so if you really need that like
exceptional activity of your biomolecule
preserved
cyclic and click chemistries are the way
to go
they are more expensive however so if
you have something where you know a
traditional conjugate might do maybe you
you want to think about using
traditional chemistry that they will be
significantly cheaper and faster however
if you have an application where you
really need that high performance
cyclic click chemistry is the way to go
all right so i spent some time talking
about how to pick a conjugation
chemistry um the other question i get
all the time uh is how do you pick a die
how do you pick a floor for there's so
many out there and there's a lot of
different categories how do you know
which is the right floor for for your
application uh even though the the
conjugation chemistries have quite a bit
of difference even simply the
fluorophores that are selected can can
make or break a conjugate depending on
your application needs so i wanted to
spend just a little bit of time
highlighting the different fluorophores
that are available and how they might
influence your selection based off your
application
so the first category i've highlighted
here is your classic dyes so these are
your simple small molecule fluorophores
that have been on the market for quite
some time
so your classic dyes such as fluorescein
texas red pacific blue uh your large
protein fluorophores rpe apc uh so these
are your markets that have or these are
your fluorophores that have defined the
market i know a lot of us have probably
trained on a
a microscope or the um
the filters were were actually named
after some of these i know uh one of
mine has a lace uh
filter that's just called tritzy because
everything was done with texas red back
then um so these classic guys still have
a use in today's market um they're
generally uh very cheap they're
generally have good initial brightness
um
but they're not the brightest things out
there they've been around for 40 50
years
they often will have acceptable signal
um in the beginning stages of an
experiment but if you have an
application that that does have the
potential for photo bleaching or maybe
you have long dwell times or it's a
longer experiment you know these these
four fours might not be bright enough
for your needs but if you do have
something where you're only you're doing
a quick measurement maybe an in vitro
assay and plenty of times these dies as
simple as they are are still more than
enough signal to get the job done but
they might not cut it in more
sophisticated assays
next up you have your second generation
of small molecule fluorophores such as
our alexa fluorides are developed here
in thermo fisher scientific so these
second generation dyes uh like the alexa
floors or the dye lights uh these are
improved small molecule fluorophores
based off of those original classic
diets of fluorescein so these dyes have
excellent fluorescent intensity much uh
can be quite a bit brighter than their
the dyes that they were derived from uh
they're often very resistant to
photobleaching so they if you're doing
an imaging experiment where you might
have a long capture time
these can preserve that signal much
longer than a classic die there's also
quite a lot of dyes out there if you
have specialty needs um one one great
example from our alexa floor line is our
frodo dyes our photo series of dyes so
these are small molecule fluorophores
that uh actually have ph sensitivity uh
so you can really have a kind of a
tailor your fluorophore to your exact
application so if you have the needs to
study internalization for an example a
frodo die will be um will be off at high
ph and then will become uh significantly
more fluorescent upon
becoming more acidic so if you're trying
to study the internalization of an
antibody perhaps these dyes provide you
that excellent brightness and then also
give you ability to actually interrogate
different biological aspects
next up we have our quantum dots
so moving away from small motion
fluorophores we'll have our our
larger than uh larger than the
antibodies themselves uh quantum dots
are a uh
small um nanocrystals so these are
metallic nanocrystals that are extremely
fluorescent very very very high signal
intensity
in neutral essence output these are
larger labels than in many cases the
biomolecules you're actually wanting to
conjugate them to um but these
nanocrystals are exceptionally resistant
to photobleaching almost to the point
where they don't photobleach at all
they're also very very stable
and so these fluorophores are extremely
good if you have the right application
to downplay their their size and um
and take the most advantage of their
very high signal output so due to their
size they can be sometimes troublesome
to to interrogate very small cytoplasmic
targets but if you have a target that is
extracellular perhaps
or a really low abundant
extracellular target so like viral code
proteins are one great example where
quantum dots can be quite useful so if
you don't have um a target or a target
that is not too hard to access by an
antibody an antibody quantum dot
conjugate can be a great choice that
will give you extremely high signal so
noise that really will let you
visualize low abundant targets if that
uh
where a small molecule fluorophore just
wouldn't cut it i've actually recently
made a conjugate this way where we had a
viral co-protein that only had 50 copies
per per virus and the only way we could
get any signal and actually
detect these these targets was with the
quantum dot so although
these quantum dots have been on the
market for 10 15 years now
and they do have limitations but if you
can if you're in a situation where
you can make the best of them they're
still extremely useful and definitely
worth considering
lastly we have the most recent uh
entries to the floor form uh space we
have our our polymer dies uh polymer
dyes so these are uh large um
organic uh polymer based tandem dyes so
you'll actually have like a
um a long
rigid polymer backbone where you'll have
a floor force uh or tandem floor four
pairs inside a polymer uh and these are
relatively new to the market uh they
were developed about five ten years ago
uh so you have your super brights from
thermo fissure you'll have your
grilling violets from bd so these types
of dyes are exceptionally bright
and have very long stokeshift
soap shifts in a tandem pair so these
are very well suited for flow cytometry
where you're making the most out of your
your given filter combinations so if you
have the need for a very very bright
signal um especially in flow cytometry
uh and you need that signal kind of like
a quantum dot almost where you need a
signal above all else and you want to
make the most of your different
excitation sources in your flow
cytometry filters um these polymer dies
really fit that build
so as one example you can have a super
bright
702 for example that's excited by your
uv laser or your blue laser your violet
laser and then you can get emission all
the way into that near ir category so
these uh floor ports are
um really interesting to work with
because they they really give you a lot
more options
in that
visible spectrum for especially for flow
cytometry they do have some downsides
even though they are polymer based small
molecules they can be quite large and
cumbersome to get inside the cell for an
intracellular target they don't always
work the best for
immune cytochemistry so if you're doing
a conventional self-staining they often
have issues so they at this point in the
market they're basically mostly
optimized for phosphatometry but in that
application they excel
all right now that we've spent some time
on you know what are conjugation what is
the biome or what's a biomolecule
conjugate what are the different types
of fluorophores and chemistries
available now i want to get to the the
fun part of the talk here where we we
talk about the latest and greatest and
what really is the state of the art
in making your own conjugate or how to
select a conjugate for for use in your
next experiment here
so one innovation i'm
i love talking about from thermo fissure
that i use personally all the time um is
our recently launched zeba protein and
dye removal columns so these are a
specialty resin recently
and specially developed just for
conjugation uh workflows that take a
modified size exclusion resin from our
ziba product line that has been modified
specifically to capture typical excess
conjugation reagents so as i mentioned
earlier in the talk in most conjugation
workflows you'll be taking a small
molecule reactive dye and you'll be
reacting that with your biomolecule and
then you almost always will have excess
unreacted
reagents that are left over that need to
be purified away before you can use that
conjugate in most workflows you'll be
using a most workflow call for a a size
exclusion column
which depending on the workflow can be
some fairly cumbersome to use uh these
columns are specifically designed to
actually capture um those those uh
reagents and retain them in a pre-packed
spin column so what that lets you do is
you can process large amounts of
conjugate
very quickly very easily and you can use
these pre-packed spin column formats uh
that have a two two minute spin and your
purification is done so basically we
sell these uh
this resin as uh pre-packed spin column
formats all the way from a half mil spin
column uh pre-packed spin column all the
way up to 10 ml
10 mil resin columns um and these are
fantastic if you're doing conjugations
yourself
you can go from an unlabeled antibody
to a purified ready to go antibody in
in the whole whole thing can take about
an hour and a half the actual
purification itself is less than 10
minutes so if you've ever uh
conjugated with some of the older uh
purification resins especially if you're
doing more than one milligram you may
have seen most workflows will call for
actually pouring your own gravity column
using a size exclusion and then
monitoring the bands as they come
through and all of that is in the past
now with these new purification resins
these are great i've
transitioned to almost exclusively using
these in the lab they're so easy to use
and they really just drastically speed
up your workflow
in addition to that workflow they also
have excellent sample recovery um and
we've seen in our own internal testing
upwards of 90 recovery sometimes even as
high as 95 recovery which compared to
traditional size exclusion resins which
are often in the range of more like 85
to 75 recovery
uh beyond the columns themselves i'm
also excited to report that we've
recently incorporated these new resins
uh into our own labeling kits so if
you've ever we sell a variety of
antibody and protein labeling kits with
the uh popular alexa floor dyes these
kits previously had uh aliquots of a
conventional size exclusion resin so uh
if you've ever as i mentioned before if
you've ever had to pack your own gravity
column we've now updated all of our most
of our kits to include this new
purification resin with these pre-packed
spin columns so if you've uh our kits
are now uh easier to use than ever uh
after your one hour labeling reaction
you simply put your crude um crude
conjugate directly onto these thin
columns you have two two minute spins
and now you're ready to go
so this is really a huge workflow
improvement a real quality of life
improvement i absolutely love these kits
i use them myself um and i've we've
really done away with these bulky
gravity columns they're just in for 99
of the time they're just a thing in the
past
all right um i've mentioned this a few
times earlier but wanted to give it its
own slide i mentioned click chemistry
and cyclic chemistry specifically
but this is a
a labeling technology that builds upon
the benefits of
click chemistry and makes it specific to
labeling iggs with basically perfect
conjugate every time
so cyclic labeling technology is all
about creating a reproducible high
performance conjugate uh every single
time with exceptional control so in this
platform we've developed a
kit workflow we're using two enzymatic
modifications of iggs and i believe also
igas and iges
you can make use of the
sc domain glycans so these are
branched glycans on the sc region of
most antibodies
and with two enzyme modifications of
these glycans we cleave off the terminal
galactose residue using beta glycosidase
uh you then add an azide group using a
genetically engineered version of galaxy
enzyme
and this now incorporates an azide group
that is ready to do with ready to react
with your favorite um click ready
label so we also have a whole library of
dibo modified so this is the reactive
alkyne groups that react with the azide
modified antibody and you can have an
azide activated antibody that's ready to
react with with any fluorophore of
interest and why this is so great is not
only does it always
modify these glycans on the fc domain
which preserves the the integrity of the
binding sites
this also is gives you complete control
over the degree of labeling so how many
fluorophores per antibody do you have so
because these glycans are are fixed
between iggs and iga and iges there's
always four of these labeling sites so
if you're using a small organic dye such
as the alexa floors you'll you'll
typically get a
degree of labeling of four every single
time which gives you exceptional
reproducibility between
batches of antibody
likewise if you're using larger proteins
like apc or rpe
these larger proteins will actually
sterically occlude that second spot on
the the branched glycan so you'll have a
dos of two uh pretty much every time
so that you have exceptional control uh
over your conjugate that also preserves
the uh the integrity of the binding
sites so this is really the premier
conjugation chemistry
to use if you want to maintain the
activity of your antibody and you really
want to have the perfect antibody as
high performance as you can make it
and then in addition the kit workflows
are all super super easy to use
they they add a couple overnight
reactions that are all hands off but the
actual
conjugation itself is a simple um
overnight reaction at room temperature
so very easy workflows in many cases
exceptionally easy purification or no
purification
so just a really uh easy workflow to
follow that gives you exceptionally well
labeled conjugate exceptionally
characterized and just really well
controlled conjugate every single time
and saving the best for last i wanted to
highlight our latest addition to thermo
fisher scientific the nova floor
platform from phytonics a recent
acquisition and now a part of thermo
fixture scientific
so we're happy to to uh um to discuss
the latest addition to our uh 404 family
the nova floors so nova floors are a
brand new technology platform uh
designed specifically for mostly flow
cytometry
that uses a dna-based scaffold to
provide tandem floor four pairs that are
precisely tuned for various filter sets
in flow cytometry and the
newly emerging spectral flow cytometry
so how these work is based off of what
we call phyton technology so these are
uh precisely controlled single-stranded
dnas that are conjugated with uh precise
fluorophores uh these then self-assemble
using phytonyx's proprietary technology
they self-assemble into these uh
double-double-started cruciform
structures
that we call the phytons
and
using this self-assembly into the phyton
we're able to precisely control the
uh fretting between the tandem pairs to
give
pretty much exactly the excitation and
mission spectra that one could ever
imagine or one could ever want or need
so we actually have
uh
next slide here
we actually have 19 different nova floor
color combinations uh that have been
tuned to really saturate the entire
visible spectrum to provide you a
conjugate that can meet any meat any
filter combination you might have in
flow cytometry or if you're dipping your
toes into spectral flow cytometry the
unique uh spectral fingerprint of each
of these noble floors really allows you
to have a nova floor
panel in spectral flow cytometry and
really just uh have
have uh so many colors all at once and
have so many conditions that that you
can really get the ideal uh
spectrophotometry experiment
uh and with that
we'll wrap up and i will take any
questions
thank you doug for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is
what makes nova floor dyes so suited for
spectral flow cytometry what
differentiates these from conventional
fluorophores
hey thanks for that question a good
point there um so nova fours have two
unique properties that make them so well
suited for for special flow cytometry uh
so first uh the the one of the easiest
aspects is that uh we because the
excitation emission is so tunable
you can really fully populate uh the
entire uv spectrum so like they
um
because the stoke shift is so tunable
and then the um like the tandem it's
really kind of the perfect tandem so
you're able to really saturate the
entire spectrum and have a label pretty
much exactly where you want it based off
of your filter combinations so in that
regard it really lets you make the most
out of your instrument
but the main thing on top of that is
that because these are all tandem die
combinations that are you know precisely
tuned they all have unique fingerprints
so every nova 4 combo has a slightly
different spectral fingerprint if you
actually look at excitation and emission
spectra and that's one of the uh you
know key
uh differences with with spectral flexor
tumors that the you know the the
algorithms are really looking for that
unique um fingerprints in order to
deconvolute the signal so uh if you take
a look at all the various node floors we
offer on our spectroviewer tour tool you
can see that they're they're all pretty
much unique uh not really owed to that
tandem that tandem die pairs that's as
part of the technology so it really
gives you uh you know each color
combination even though they're all nova
floors uh they have unique fingerprints
in their expectation emission spectra
which allows those spectrophotometry
algorithms to deconvolute that where
that signal is coming from
okay great question
great thank you our next question is
where can i get cyclic conjugates i
haven't seen conjugates for sale with
this technology
that's also a good question um so cyclic
is one of our uh it's one of our newer
platforms uh currently we offer
conjugation kits um
for for users to to do it themselves so
we offer kits cyclic conjugation kits um
in various size ranges ranging from
microgram quantities up to five
milligram kits uh so these are kits
designed to take and your own antibody
um prep them within uh the cyclic
azide modification and then have them
ready to
uh to conjugate with a given um
psychology label of your choice
so we offer these conjugation kits for
sale
but we don't have any uh off-the-shelf
conjugates for sale with this method and
part of that is just because the
technology is so new um but we do offer
custom conjugation services uh with our
cyclic technology um so if you're ever
interested in if you don't wanna do the
kits yourself or you know you wanna to
outsource that labor uh we do have a
custom foundation service where you can
you can custom order a cyclic conjugate
for your application
perfect thank you
next question how long do click
chemistry reactions take between dvco
and an azide as you have shown in your
slide i have seen in the literature that
it takes as little as 15 minutes but i
found overnight reactions are much more
complete
yeah so that's a good point so the the
reaction kinetics between uh click
handles are all slightly different and
there's actually um some literature out
there where the the different kinetics
are actually defined between the
different click handles so uh one of the
most common ones you'll see out there
the kind of the generics like handle of
the the dbco so that's kind of a generic
one uh for our thermo fissure conjugates
we usually use uh dibo or s dibo
conjugates and the reaction kinetics are
actually slightly different between
those dbco is one of the faster reacting
kinetics
and it does actually i think as it's
mentioned in the question um you
actually can see the majority of the
reaction done in 15 minutes um in my own
hands it's often gone to completion
after two hours um but due to its you
know the the kinetics out there is a um
between handles is a little hard to find
so most most uh
most workflows will just kind of give
you a blanket statement of do an
overnight reaction to make sure it's
gone to completion and that's a good
general practice to follow if you're not
sure about the kinetics of a given click
handle it's just safer to let it go
overnight but in the case of uh if you
do know the reaction connects like for
example dbco is one of the faster
reacting ones um it's often worth like
testing that yourself the um in my hands
dvco's is usually done within an hour or
less uh but it won't be completely gone
to completion in 15 minutes uh some of
the other conjugates out there like
daibo they they're a little slower
so there might be done in four to six
hours and so most people will just let
those go overnight just to because it's
easier um but they do vary a little bit
but uh the most common workflow you'll
see is overnight but if you do want to
look that up the reaction connects do
vary and you can you can actually cut a
lot of time out there if you
know what you're given kinetic bar for
the click handle
all right thank you next question does
the click labeling method work for igm
antibodies
uh so not really so the igms um because
of that you know like kind of touch or
um
pentimer structure there the the glycans
aren't accessible um and so it's really
it really only works on the glycans that
are present on iggs iges and igas
so it's unfortunately not currently
compatible with with ibm
okay thank you next question what is the
smallest
molecule you can use in the ziva columns
yeah so um the columns that i
highlighted today are are um built off
of our ziba side exclusion resin which
is actually based off of an exclusion
limit of of seven thousand uh seven
thousand daltons so uh it's actually a
combo purification method so
um as i mentioned is the base resin is
this uh seven thousand uh zebra size
exclusion resin and so that seven
thousand is your exclusion limit so
anything smaller than seven thousand
will go around the resin um or it will
go a world sorry excuse me go through
the resin it will be retained at that
top band um whereas anything larger than
that will will go through so it's all
about what's the size of the molecule
you're trying to purify so if you are
trying to purify a you know like a
smaller protein um
7000 is that general rule of thumb
but the beauty of the the
zeba the biotin and diet binding columns
those have ligands that are specifically
designed to capture um small molecule uh
reagents so um you really just as long
as your your bio molecule is larger than
seven thousand that's the main thing um
but we do actually have an rpis the
sorry the product insert sheet um and we
do detail out the different reaction
conditions that are the things you want
to keep in mind when you're when you're
using uh different bond molecules um so
that 7000 is a is a cut off for the
resin itself but due to the additional
lincoln's we recommend that uh you know
a general rural thumb is a 50 000 kill
or 50 000 dolphin biomolecule is kind of
a good um
a good thing to keep in mind we find
sometimes depending on your modification
of that biomolecule uh sometimes the
ligands will will hold on a little bit
more uh to those modifications but uh um
it's all stepped out in the instructions
but generally speaking the the sweet
spot is anything over 50 000 works
exceptionally well and you get an
excellent recovery um going below 50 000
it still works well but you have there's
a
a little bit more considerations given
what is your floor for using or was a
small molecule that sometimes can alter
the retention times but
in general that's a good rule of thumb
is 50 000 or higher
okay thank you our next question is do
you provide any fluorescent labels in
the swir spectrum
so the farthest we go out is the near ir
so we have for small molecules uh and
and polymer dyes most of them will go
out to around 800 nanometers um
that's not really s-w-i-r it's really
more near ir that's a good question
though actually let me follow up by
email on that to give a more thorough
answer
perfect thank you
next question i have a problem washing a
dvco die from fixed cells any suggestion
for wash steps
so the the um dvco reaction itself is
extremely specific it's bio-orthogonal
meaning it won't actually enter it won't
cross-react with anything in the cells
so what that's meaning if you're having
a dvco dye um that's
sticking to your fixed cells um
sometimes it's not coming from the
handle itself it's probably coming more
from the fluorophore so sometimes if you
have a more hydrophobic dyes that are
just stickier dyes in general um that
could be the problem um if you have the
azide modified right so the other
partner in that reaction if that is
having non-specific binding then the
dbco die will follow it so you really
want to keep an eye towards
what where is your azide label is there
potential like
um
cross reactivity on the azide step
because the dbco dies will just react
wherever there's an azide so if you have
off target
azide modification in your cells um then
you'll you'll see
uh that either bbc are reacting to those
off-target azides and coming up this
background or it could be that the diet
itself is just um
you know non-covalently sticking to
yourselves and isn't washing off so you
could look at the
the floor for itself and see if you've
got a you know a stickier floor for um
in general mostly like supports are
pretty not sticky so it's not usually a
problem um but yeah i would look at that
look at the floor for and then also look
at where is your azide modification
happening and is that specific enough
for you
perfect it looks like we have one final
question
have you done antibody with
yes oligonucleotide what is the bind
site for it and how to evaluate the
conjugation result
yeah so that's a that's a good question
um so oligonucleotides um actually can
be conjugated with a lot of different
methods it just kind of depends on um
what it follows the same um
same thought process for for a general
conjugation it's you're just thinking it
comes with a little bit more um
more background that you have to
consider so like what's the size of the
oligonucleotide how do you want to
attach the oligonucleotide so do you
want to use
um amine chemistry cysteine chemistry
there's lots of different ways you could
do it it just really depends on
what type of modification are you do you
want to put on your
oligonucleotide so like for example you
can have a
an amine group on your five prime end
for example of your nucleotide um you
can use and you can use that for amine
targeted crosslinking uh you could have
you know a sulfidel group modified um
you can there's lots of different ways
to do it in general you treat the
oligonucleotide as as the label um and
you follow it
it's compatible with a lot of the same
um
the same chemistries uh the only thing
you have to consider is
uh
it's a little bit of a different thought
process as far as how might that affect
your protein so you're putting a large
negatively charged string onto that
antibody so you have to design you want
to try to keep that degree of
modification relatively low um and then
you also have to be wary of you know
you're purifying instead of purifying
out small molecules you're purifying out
larger oligonucleotides so depending on
the size of that oligonucleotide your
purification strategy might have to
change generally speaking in most
conjugations your your protein or your
your biomolecule of interest is
significantly larger than your
modification so size of fusion
chromatography works really well to
separate those out easily if you're
starting to think about
larger modifications like whether
protein or ligonucleotide you have to
change your purification strategy
because your modification might be
similarly sized so oligonucleotides can
range obviously based off of their
sequence length so if you have a really
short oligo then that might be pretty
easy to
react and pretty easy to purify but if
you have a longer oligonucleotide that
might be
as heavy as your uh as your protein
all right thank you so much doug do you
have any final comments for our audience
i actually see one last question popped
up i'm happy to answer that we have some
time
sure yeah let me pull that up
okay so final question can the zebra
columns be used with q dots to remove
linking molecules
uh shortening 3s uh they work great
actually um so the cubot modifications
you know after most foreclosure using
the header by functional crosslinkers
so the ziva columns work fantastic to
remove those linking molecules and the
extra weight from the q dots makes it
elute really nicely from from the zebra
columns
all right thank you so much do you have
any final comments for our audience
uh final comments which is really and
we're really excited to bring a lot of
new technologies to making your own bio
conjugate and and how to how to design
and buy a conjugate your shop for one um
we've it's never been this easy to make
your own conjugates so if it's something
that you're interested in making your
own tools for for your experiments it's
never been easier to make your own
reagents these days um i wish i had had
all these tools when i was in grad
school certainly would have made my life
easier and i think what we have on offer
will certainly make your life easier too
so hopefully this was useful and uh i'm
happy to answer any questions by email
for follow thanks everybody
thank you again doug for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye